We are unfortunately potentially approaching
a very dangerous period, not ideologically,
but in a very sort of literal and and pragmatic
sense, a dangerous period, what could be dangerous
for many Americans?
Because President Donald Trump, in his latest
series of rage tweets, amplified a message
reportedly from one of his fans that things
are soon to escalate.
And it could be a dangerous moment in America,
which, of course, is likely to have the effect
of planting that idea in his followers and
actually making it so a self-fulfilling prophecy
of sorts.
So let me back up and kind of give you the
genesis of all of this yesterday morning after
a couple of days of relative calm on Twitter,
and I used that phrase very, very loosely.
Donald Trump amplified some dangerous messages
and also sent some messages of his own, attacking
Joe Biden, attacking Republican Governor Brian
Camp.
And this now is getting to be extremely concerning
over what is going to be a five or six week
period of this nonsense.
I predict it started with a sort of strange
all capital letters tweet where Donald Trump
said merely wisdom and courage, very strange
thing to say.
And then he he quoted an unnamed fan, supposedly
from one of his rallies, as reported supposedly
by propaganda network own.
And this is where Donald Trump amplifies the
idea of a dangerous moment with huge escalation,
saying, quote, and this is quote, quote, This
is me quoting Trump quoting and quoting a
Trump supporter.
People are upset.
They have a right to be.
Georgia not only supported Trump in 2016,
but now that that's untrue.
Of course, this is the only state in the Deep
South that went for Biden.
Have they lost their minds?
And yeah, I mean, Biden won.
That's it.
This is going to escalate dramatically.
This is a very dangerous moment in our history.
The fact that our country is being stolen,
a coup is taking place in front of our eyes
and the public can't take this anymore.
Now, that's all untrue.
And Trump quotes a Trump fan at a Georgia
rally, Parolin, and then says bad.
After that, Donald Trump went after Republican
Georgia Governor Brian Kemp.
Why?
Because Kemp won't illegally steal the election
for Trump.
Kemp is no good guy.
I really want people to understand this.
When when I've been saying this week, Kemp
doesn't seem willing to try to steal Georgia
for Trump, I believe Kemp can be horrible.
Kemp participated in voter suppression in
the very election in which he was a candidate
for governor against Stacey Abrams.
Kemp has overseen the continued purging of
voter rolls and everything else that we've
been talking about.
And I wouldn't even put it past Kemp to try
to steal Georgia if doing so would give Trump
the presidency.
What what may be going on here is Kemp realizes,
even if I try to fraudulently steal Georgia
for Trump, Trump still doesn't win.
It just reduces the number of electoral votes
by which Joe Biden wins.
And so, listen, Kemp's no good guy, but Trump's
furious with him because Kemp won't try to
steal it for him.
Trump tweeting, How does Governor Brian Kemp
allow certification of votes without verifying
signatures?
And despite the recently released tape of
ballots being stuffed, remember that those
tapes have been completely debunked.
His poll numbers have dropped like a rock.
He is finished as governor.
I have no I mean, listen, as we spoke about
yesterday with Benjamin Dixon, there's a lot
of Republican infighting in Georgia.
This may all damage in the end calculation
and the final math.
This may hurt Brian Kemp or it may not with
Georgia Republicans, we don't know, but it's
certainly not clear at this time.
And, of course, most of these tweets flagged
by Twitter as being misleading or disputed.
And then Donald Trump merely calling on the
Supreme Court to steal the election for him,
saying, quote, The Supreme Court has a chance
to save our country, capitalist country from
the greatest capital election abuse in the
history of the United States.
Seventy eight percent of the people feel,
no, the election was rigged.
So when Trump chooses to quote and amplify
some alleged follower who's saying this is
about to escalate and this will become a dangerous
moment for the United States, it's very, very
dangerous for Trump to do.
Now, Trump can hide behind.
I didn't say it.
I was quoting a fan.
But it's fanning the flames when the president
does this.
It's dog whistling when the president does
this.
And this could get very ugly very quick.
And I have no idea what Trump supporters are
willing to do, what are they capable of as
they are inevitably seeing?
I mean, it's happening daily.
Every lawsuit getting tossed each day.
Trump continues to claim he won.
And each day leads us to nothing other than
being one day closer to Joe Biden being sworn
in as president on January 20th.
So it is scary.
And I get emails, you know, two, three, four
emails a day, not dozens, like when I say
the wrong thing, but two, three, four emails
a day from people who are saying, listen,
I live in this red state.
I'm worried about this or that because these
people are furious.
These people literally believe the things
that Donald Trump is saying.
They're not you know, they don't interpret
I was robbed as I should have won, but I didn't.
They interpret I was robbed as specific.
Democrats manipulated votes and stole and
cheated and hacked and all this different
stuff.
And that the will of the people was that Donald
Trump would win.
They literally believe that that's what Trump
is saying.
And who knows what they're potentially willing
to do.
We all we can do is follow it and see and
hope
for the best.